hi everyone its Johanna here September
is coming and it's time to spread the
love because it's my month today's
workout it's about getting rid of your
love handles yes a very problematic
areas for most women based on my own
personal experience besides doing the
workout with me today swimming in my
opinion is one of the best way to burn
fat and to get rid of love handles it
has worked for me and I'm sure it will
work for you as well so what I would
encourage you to do is to do this
workout today and also to swim at least
3 times a week for 30 to 40 minutes it's
really good to burn the fat and it's
really good to sculpt your body and to
give you the nice curve and to get rid
of the excess love handles ok so try to
do it and give it 6 weeks are you sure
you will notice a huge difference so
let's start the workout so to start the
record you'll need a dumbbell about 3
kilos or you can make your own dumbbell
using a milk bottle or any other bottles
ok so let's start by doing some warm-up
at the same time we will be working on
our obliques as well to set and we're
going to do is just to extend our arms
and crunch the sides ok so let's do 30
cycles on each side and another 30
seconds before moving on to the next
workout ready let's go really stretch
and reach that's it all the way up and
crunch you should be feeling your side
obliques breaking at the same time
you're bringing your heart rate up good
so touch up up and crunch good keep
going
really reach up extend and
okay plus q1 and change
same thing reach and crunch good job
can you really feel the obliques working
good keep going
reach out look up and punch good ten
more seconds
crunch slide four seconds and rest the
next workout what we're going to do is
to extend our arms twist our entire body
and bring our arms close to our knees
okay so it's twist and crunch this is
when you can grab a dumbbell and to use
your dumbbell to add the lecture weight
so I'm ready same thing 30 seconds on
each side so extend and coach good so
really cut it in really twist my body
and crunch it all the way get rich
crunch
imagine you're reaching all the way up
and crunching all the way let's go and
change
here's side same thing twist and crunch
we twist all the way to your side hats
twisting and bring it in reach all the
way up which crunch and get so just drop
your weights and now we're just going to
stand and twist side to side
okay just for fun seconds and grab your
net because we will be working on the
floor can you feel your heart rate going
up good job you should already be
feeling your obliques warming up so just
twist site suicide 10 more seconds and
get Brabham at the first workout is
called twist rope so grab the dumbbell
instead of doing your usual twist what
we want to do is imagine you're rowing a
boat so draw a figure of 8 and to twist
it okay that way you will work more your
obliques and you can really feel it the
same thing
do it with your lips lifted off all on
the floor so we'll be doing 15 on each
side let's go let's lift it up and just
drop Figaro things get on your dumbbell
really grow and - it's good that's for
figure-of-eight
do well
jump halfway there
with more good throw big figure of eggs
last three doing very well with her legs
up bend your body slightly and good now
Drago dumbbells play the floor the next
courtyard is sight conscious so bring
your knees in your legs into a
triangular shape and what we're going to
do is to look straight up and just a
crunch side to side and touch your
ankles okay same thing fifteen on each
side and try not to rest in between
that's no good
so really crunch and go all the way as
far as you can reach good job there you
go really crunch your side up hit
and so seven more
your job going +3 good job
so now let's get up we want to between
side planks so get onto your side and
start in our left side again arms on the
floor next degrees and place your feet
together
if you can't stable yourself stabilize
yourself if you always case one feet on
the floor or you can start on your knees
to begin with okay so let's get on to a
side plank lift it up and what we're
going to do is to live our body up bring
it down and bring it up and we'll be
doing 15 on each side good sit down and
crunch it so you should really be
pinning your last glutes working good
job
we're absolutely - or just fit outside
the side get 10 more small when you're
working out good we did last 5 can you
feel that
ABS good now let's change sides same
thing exactly the same thing you can
choose to go on your knees or on your
toes ready let's go down and up you will
feel that one side is always stronger
than the other for me this side it's
much easier good up ah
10 more doing very good
you're never no pain no gain
we sweat in order to blend the stuff
get keep going last five seas Milan last
one and good now let's get into what I
call the spider-man workout so onto your
hands onto your toes and what you want
to do is bring your knees and just
crunch excitement's okay so let's do ten
of that good to really crunch assign us
to go back straight don't drop your back
so really crunch and video sign up
looking good over there
very good keep going
okay no major investments a walk because
we're getting back onto the same
position and what we want to do is to
twist it in now so right knee to left
elbow good leg twisted still working on
our legs
we'll be doing ten of this
last one and give the thing with the
apps we're done is that people tend to
forget to work the lower back which is
really important because it's part of a
core as well so what we want to be
working now it's our low back workout
it's called a super member account I've
done this before but those of you do
know what it is basically just lie flat
on your belly you can extend your arms
forward if you want to bring your legs
slightly wide apart and what you want to
be doing is to use your lower back to
lift your body up that way you're
crunching you're working on your lower
back if you prefer you can always place
your hands on your chin and to lift it
up
same thing we will be doing fifteen and
really squeeze and pull your lower back
as you're off ready let's go so I'm
going to put on my chin
ready imagine you're flying go up holy
for three counts I'll bring it back down
don't rest and up again good
so try to go all the way down always
keep the resistance good up punch a
little back up you really feel it all
back working good soul if your upper
body and lift your legs up up good job
slow and steady up on wheel
down up halfway there good go seven more
good up
um
that's for doing it you squeeze the low
back
good job that is common core and that is
important last three last two and one
and just relax and less I guess you know
what you will be doing now second round
of the exact same workout got really
sitting up slightly okay so to stretch
it out
are you ready front to you let's do the
entire workout without stopping that
scam you jump and crunch get 30 seconds
on each side reach all the way up and
crunch in okay good job keep going bring
out everything okay keep your breathing
give it a rhythm to your breathing okay
- seconds and we're changing crunch and
change let's go up good
oh we are imagine
doing it let's go
all this workout can be done at home and
really you do not need a big space at
all last five seconds and grabbing your
dumbbell and very twisting
good grab a dumbbell and that's holding
all the way up and twist really twist
your body extend and twist if you find
it difficult you can drop it down then
good job keep going very nice really
really nice nice and control last three
seconds and we're changing the other way
and to keep your balance twist all the
way extend up and after this grab your
mat as fast as you can because you're
going straight down onto the floor last
ten seconds please five seconds
oh yeah we're supposed to come and twist
nothing mom sorry let's jump into it
before we go down onto the floor
I've almost missed that out let's go
isn't this fun jump into it get down
real Twitter feeds and green side to
side ten more seconds grab your mat and
we're going down on to the floor
good grab your mat so get down on the
mat the first leg out is Rowan twist
okay so leave your legs out
Oh H end of the dumbbell let's go feet
on each side really draw a figure of
eight good job doing it three twist your
feel your obliques try to keep your legs
steady and tighten your ass good ten
more
you got a imagine you're moving boat
very good plus six and after this grid
went straight into side punches three
more plus one and draw the dumbbells and
let's line the board and then to finish
side okay
so touch good really thin side ass okay
cut your angles
look up to avoid any pain on your neck
halfway there
Oh is there and after this let's get
straight into side plank all right let's
go on your knees or on your toes okay up
and let's bring it down and back up
fifteen on each side get up we squeeze
your left please
I was there doing it but let's work
together to get rid off that love
handles last bye
stay strong come on let's go
last two and change sides this side side
should feel easier for you now up go
these are all strength workout your
muscles to turn your body up at the same
time it's going to do you really good to
sculpt your body last step let's get one
thing straight smile give it a 7 and
we're going straight into spine a plus 3
and good so on your knees on pause on
your arms let's go 10 on each side
we squeeze and feels like everything
keep your core tight stay strong over
there
and after this you get a really sharp
rest okay
one more good now just run into wall and
we're getting straight back into the
same position and twist the opposite
direction plus you're up and twist
taking handle each side good
sweaty scared sweat makes you look sexy
let's go last fall the steer last one
alright top on my belly and how low back
it's very important so on so forth
next forward have you chin up look up
pull it down good this is a lot summer
camp down up squeeze a little bit down
you job imagine you're flying this is
the best you can do come up
Plus 10 up squeeze it
keep going slow and steady
1 2 3
down good squeeze really quick your body
is high up super squeeze it get up
that's 5 over there hey stay strong up
cinnamons up last 3 up last two and one
more let's hold it up oh we squeeze it
all back holy and relax just take your
time to brand can relax if you're
sweating like me it's good because we
like that if you're out of your breath
it's really good because that means
you've worked hard and this is my last
hand work out don't forget to do it with
three times
swimming per week it's really effective
you burn your fat off and you'll give
you a nice sculpted
slime okay so share with your little
friends don't forget to like this page
and also please do subscribe to my
youtube channel for more fitness and
nutritional videos and do befriend me on
Facebook as well for more daily updates
on whatever to